this is your homie are you guys in
relationships
no I'm not with each other
this guy's that worried about looking
gay I heard you the first time
[__] I said are you in
relationships not are you in a
relationship you are way too
uncomfortable people thinking you're gay
I'm like this guy is sucking somebody's
they don't want him to know about it I'm
gonna ask you because you're way less
defensive is your cousin dating anybody
yes yes okay where are they he's not
comfortable people seeing him
he was like she's on vacation
Joe the strangest thing
is this thing then I would have laughed
we would have had a good time she bro
she XX chromosomes all right she's got
that [__] straight